welcome to this video and playing my
nemesis year allah gasps yeah and I am
trying to do something crazy aggressive
here if possible I mean it probably yeah
when you place the driest stuff ever so
it's it's difficult and maybe maybe I
can can do some dry for quick
development here sorry the porn yes
what is 25 completely moronic maybe the
text a tomb okay just try it I mean what
I don't want to do a so to get to one of
those idiotic end games again where he
wins on time with them okay so if I take
here take here Bishop e3 Bishop e3 is
there something I'm not really hmm can
go rook to d1 should be to King Day to
Knight a5 maybe a Knight a5 to a check
back come on let's try that 95 just a
tech b3 okay I can take yet again
I cannot do b5 I can't play 96 now this
is maybe interesting just try to take on
c4 the bad thing is that this all costs
time that might be crucial later
okay it's just retreating mm-hmm okay
okay maybe better but to take with this
year v5 is certainly the more
problematic piece in comparison so
taking them I have two bishops but they
are not doing that much at the moment
down about one minute on the clock but
it's still it's still okay I'm not not
overly worried about that
yeah yeah maybe I should have prevented
that this night night a to and stuff
could be could be tricky
yeah I should have retreated to his 7
beforehand this would have been a good
idea
nobody is suffering a bit Jim I can just
take it yeah all that one
not sure how bad it is really forgetting
85 you haven't totally okay yeah it's
always frustrating yeah it's not a bad
player the frustrating thing is that
this is playing on time in our positions
what is really playing well at times
yeah you will get a 7 a sub they cannot
do much about that
yeah nothing to do about it
he will get this Jack Jack just can just
hope for some come on to play with
Bishop you won you should have to
sometimes if King d2 these kind of
things if I move my bishop though yeah
okay I can't do that I'm still - still
here yes I can attack before my bishop
on c4 is quite strong
c4 it protects everything and I'm
attacking me for what is what is he
doing now
exactly
hmm
hmm
we can I mean before I can take it later
was my idea so what is this di of f6 and
then Bishop f6 and route g7 I can go
look G ed doesn't look great but I
couldn't couldn't do much else
we should back here to you one night f3h
for what maybe 93% somewhere it's
watching
it'd be time warning before Knight f3 b3
night it won't be true and I'm promoting
no idea no idea man I cannot calculate
it I'm is route b7 he has rupees 7
unfortunately yeah a stupid
miscalculation rupee 7 hmm
Jim what about those pawns
check check check check check check
check check
what for face time
screw you I'm sorry about that for all
the - watching but this is really
something that I wanted to win I have
lost so many games against this guy with
when he tried to win on time in this
kind of idiotic situations and it was
really really time that I win one of
those wow I have no idea
probably I don't know I mean with this
beep on and so on it should be good for
like somehow it wasn't real and of
course it I just stumbled into it
somehow but chillin I already don't know
it was it was very tricky him with those
mating ideas and so on this this and now
before wins which I played and I can go
b3 I can go b3 I was thinking I cannot I
thought he can take b2 I have Bishop b5
I overlooked Bishop b5 so I had the
right idea and I was winning but I
didn't see this Bishop b5
yeah I'm Sam I'm winning again here I
can take now and rugby 7 yeah okay but I
had no time whatsoever 18 seconds I was
just hoping that my activity would would
net me something Luke 8 who is winning
and why there must be a maid there is
made we should f2 Bishop t54 checkmate
Wow
okay great stuff
Bishop f2 Bishop g5 mate he cannot
prevent it ok me all right 15 seconds I
was basically pre moving now Luke H
again Winstead I was I was content that
I'm able to move very quickly here with
my I have everything protected with this
light square bishop and check this
allowed me to play shine news channe
yeah I ran for route before of course I
know I'm already was quicker much
quicker with my pre moves ok so I'm
sorry for them for the sparing at the
end but this is a personal matter here
with this guy sorry
thanks for watching still